el hombre de 33 años estaba a punto de
embarcar en un avión de parís a riad
cuando la policía fronteriza francesa lo
detuvo su nombre jalit alotaibi es
objeto de una orden de detención
internacional emitida por turquía el
sospechoso de formar parte de un
escuadrón de 26 guardias sauditas que
asesinaron y desmembraron a llama al
caso guía hace tres años el periodista
destacado crítico de la cúpula del reino
desapareció mientras visitaba el
consulado saudita en estambul en octubre
de 2018 su cuerpo nunca fue encontrado
la prometida turca de caso y se
congratuló de la detención instó a
francia a juzgarlo a extraditarlo a otro
país que lo lleve ante la justicia
la embajada saudita en parís se emitió
un comunicado en el que afirmaba que el
hombre detenido no tiene nada que ver
con el caso en cuestión y exigía su
liberación inmediata añadió que todos
los implicados en el asesinato de
kaesong habían sido condenados y estaban
en la cárcel arabia saudita juzgó en
secreto a 11 sospechosos y condenó a 8
el juicio fue ampliamente criticado por
activistas y por el consejo de derechos
humanos de la onu mientras tanto turquía
acuso y juzgo a 20 personas en rebeldía
entre ellas la letal o time y el brutal
asesinato de caso que tensó las
relaciones diplomáticas entre arabia
saudita y occidente el príncipe heredero
mohamed bin salman ha negado
rotundamente cualquier papel mientras
que un informe de los servicios de
inteligencia de eeuu dijo que él había
aprobado el asesinato del periodista la
detención se produce apenas unos días
después de que el presidente francés
emmanuel macrón se reuniera con bin
salman el primer líder occidental
importante que lo visita desde el
asesinato